welcome to this video playing fernanda
motta I had a Smith Mora against him
earlier so maybe he hasn't looked up his
lines i will just play exactly the same
thing and see what is coming up with
nice looks a bit better yeah this is
exactly how you play that I wonder who
is there some way for me to wait so that
I can take on c3 air probably not yet ok
very often it sir it's a it's a good
idea to capture 1c3 enter then play
against the double pawns I don't know
why he wants this bishop on g5 this is
really not where it belongs why
definitely does not want to trade the
bishops and this is what takes takes I
made a mated on age 7 yeah weird
think about it still takes takes 93-95
yeah I met at home that's not good
Knight e5 is interesting and okay i mean
it's it's it's okay for black in any
case but this is an in this is an
interesting way to play take here then
then take on I can do this then take on
e5 what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to transfer this pawn to e5 so that I
can play on the dark square Bishop age 6
is a totally anti positional move in the
structure as it weakens the dark squares
very am very severely and now I get the
night to reform its it's not like a flex
winning or something but it's already
quite comfortable he might have some
idea with night be five this is
something that could happen once we open
it to a switch off the Rachel I mean I
can go nighty too we have this is bliss
is probably probably what he will do is
just just about in time to get this in
that's a shame
ok
okay then probably this wasn't that
great just just from from from a timing
kind of viewpoint what Queen B so this
looks like okay whatever I'm really came
this is the kind of opponent where you
never guess a move because it's just
playing to playing something totally
what you don't expect at form Wow okay
let's just take this
so probably 95-year not don't really see
him no he's not doing that as well so
yeah I can I might as well just play
some movement he's playing something
different anyway okay so takes here I
wonder if I take on c4 I probably has
night a form i was i was thinking knight
c6 any way to get to e5 maybe
daddy's got this very well known Swiss
cheese formation everything's like
totally week but maybe find some sort of
miracle tactic against my king if I get
the e5 the e5 pawn this should be good
no that's okay no it can take on each
subject yeah of course of course this is
how you can lose against such a player
check it's just neat just one second and
it's not happening gather the miracle
tactic or the stupid blunder one of
those Lex may be still okay well Scott
does not have very very good piece
placement
I'm not quite sure what the best piece
placement for me is just activating
stuff can try to get the night to see
five
hmm not sure about all that not sure if
my rook is good on a five is big
difficulties forward gym time morning
you
maybe b5 was was an idea I can take ok
we can take so it wasn't an idea let's
say not a good idea
hmm interesting
my time oh my time why do i do a five if
this is like I cannot what is this it's
like doing for for a ruckus tell Brooks
tale maging itself or something that's a
weird idea
ok 494 hmm cannot do it I can get just
check them I can play king d 3 year what
a game what the game really see 70 check
check check
yeah this was stronger even before but
it does not matter really check check
check
check check check mate yeah yeah this is
I got the idiot of the Year prize for
this game I mean it's always frustrating
if you if you do some yeah there's this
type of position where you can really
only do this by blundering material
which I which I just reliably manage
them if you just do this or King g7 it's
just resigned step I take a five next
week and it's over I just you're taking
just idiotic to overlook that stuff
enter the position is still so resilient
that that white can basically not win
and term they're even winning chances
for black I think along the way but I
couldn't really do anything with this
time yeah and the a5 is just like oh wow
if I how can you play that I mean this
is something where you really am no this
is just so idiotic just just just any
move here the problem is what is my
doing let's say it takes and they're all
take a look what kind of what peace is
he moving now he's in a zoosk long if
this rook moves I take this with check
if this route moves I take you for if
you place this okay i can i can do cat
this is already a positional draw my
chest has no way no way forward but a
five is really like a brain-dead move to
totally totally totally geotech and
Bishop d1 is really the problem trapping
the rook and tlk there's a ton of ton of
stupid jokes probably by both sides with
with no time on the clock but the real
the real deal is like here where I mean
playing F form and so on this is simply
I mean unspeakable
said totally unplayable I just need to
to not blunder this blunder this
exchange route d7 king d king g7
whatever may be this this is the best
one because it also covers covers here
and it goes like this just to show how
this is nothing I just block on e5 he
has a dead bishop from the get-go on f1
and yeah this is just over okay well
thanks for watching